A whole bunch of people emailed me about CNN's
Anderson Cooper interviewing the mayor of
Las Vegas, Nevada, Carolyn Goodman.
And it is something else.
So I want to look at a few clips with you.
Anderson was visibly stunned by how ignorant
and incompetent the mayor of Las Vegas is.
How she got to become mayor of Las Vegas is
a different story.
But let's look at some of the interview.
And Carolyn Goodman is desperate for Las Vegas
to open up.
This includes casinos.
This includes the Las Vegas strip in general.
But she doesn't actually have any idea how
it could happen safely other than to wildly
dismiss every concern that Anderson Cooper
brings up and say that, listen, they're going
to have to figure it out.
Let's get right into it.
There's a Chinese researchers have shown how
this virus spreads.
I just want to put up for our viewers.
I just want to put up our viewers.
This is a red handle thing here to not just
China.
This isn't China.
This is a Vegas, Nevada.
Wow.
OK.
That's really ignorant.
This is a restaurant and the yellow shirt
to say that's an ignorant, ignorant statement.
That's that's a restaurant.
And yes, it's in China.
But there are human beings, too.
That yellow is a person who is asymptomatic
and infected and all those other red circles
or other diners who that one diner pass the
virus to.
All those other people became infected in
a restaurant that had air conditioning.
And they believe it was the air conditioning,
which part helped the virus and spread to
all those other.
Remember the Legionnaires disease in 1976
and Philadelphia came all through the air
conditioning.
You don't remember because you're younger.
I remember Mary Typhoid Mary, who I think
passed away.
Well, anyway, during the late thirties, rode
the buses, was a cook, and she was asymptomatic
and she spread it.
Eh, eh?
The fear of getting typhoid.
And she never showed a sign of it.
And she lived most of her life.
Quarantine.
The reality was, I think 58 people passed
away from typhoid.
And so we're aware of this.
We learned from history.
We've had Ebola.
We've had that West Nile, but we've had polio.
We've had these.
None of those were infectious in Las Vegas.
I mean, you didn't have people with Ebola
on a casino floor.
You know what?
If you don't know that well, yet, you do.
Because if you had a neighbor of mine died
from West Nile.
Yeah.
Her neighbor died of West Nile.
She has no idea what she's talking about.
Listing other diseases.
Isn't anything.
It's not an argument.
It's not a reason to do anything.
It's not a reason not to do anything.
Legionnaires in the 1970s, what is this woman
talking about?
And it continues and it actually gets even
worse.
You're you're I mean, you're talking encouraging
hundreds of thousands of people to come to
Las Vegas to get the financial losses people
are suffering, which is awful.
But you're encouraging.
I mean, hundreds of thousands of people coming
there in casinos, smoking, drinking, touching
slot machines, breathing, circulated air and
then returning home to states around America
and countries around the world.
Doesn't that sound like a virus petri dish?
I mean, how is that?
No.
It sounds like you're being an alarmist.
I'm not.
I've lived a long life.
I grew up in the heart of Manhattan.
I know what it's like to be with subways and
on buses and began going to elevators.
I think you are by saying of what you have
just said.
So you don't believe there should be any social
distancing?
You don't believe that this is.
I believe there should be.
Of course.
How do you do that in a casino?
That's up to them to figure out.
So it got really, really bad, and I would
encourage you to check out the full interview
on YouTube on CNN's Web site.
Now, the one thing I can say about Carolyn
Goodman is she looks remarkably good for being
an 81 year old woman.
I would not have guessed she was 81 by any
means.
So congratulations to her.
Maybe some of that dry Vegas heat is helping
her remain extremely spry into her 80s.
Other than that, I don't have much positive
that I can really say about her.
And there's an interesting thing happening
where as the world does become more and more
focused on slowing down the spread of Corona
virus and most of the planet understands what
we're fighting here and why we're doing it.
In comparison, the crazy people are getting
a lot louder.
The anti lockdown protesters around the country
seem completely out
of it.
I mean, blocking traffic and making it difficult
for ambulances to bring patients who need
medical care to a hospital.
It's crazy.
Carolyn Goodman as mayor of Las Vegas seems
completely disconnected from reality at this
point.
When someone like Carolyn Goodman doesn't
deal, in fact, but just abstractly talks about
the economy opening up and ignores the issue
of the virus spread itself, they are essentially
saying, I don't care who lives or dies, but
we need to get money flowing.
It's the embrace of what I talked about on
Wednesday.
Maybe it was Tuesday.
Republicans embracing let them die, let them
die in exchange for whatever they've identified
as a higher priority.
This is the approach that they're taking.
Most people aren't going to fall for it.
And yesterday, I pointed out mayors can't
really open cities.
Governors can't really open states.
The president can't really
open the country.
It's up to the people to do it.
And in the case of Las Vegas, even if it,
quote, opened, there aren't many flights coming
in and out.
Foreign flights are almost completely cut
off.
Most people recognize that a crowded casino,
even if it's open, even if you could go and
sit down at a blackjack table and get the
free drinks brought to you and the entire
thing.
Most people recognize that it doesn't make
sense to do that right now.
So even if she opens Vegas, it's not going
to be much of an opening.
And I think that that's an important thing
to remember.
Regardless of the ad, increasingly Astroturf
protests to reopen polling shows that most
Americans are prioritizing slowing the spread
over saving the economy.
And I'm not saying the economic destruction
is not significant.
We now have 26 million people
who in five weeks have filed new unemployment
insurance claims.
I'm right there with you.
But over the medium and long term, we are
better off if we don't have resurgence of
the virus because of opening too early.
Carolyn Goodman doesn't seem to understand
that in a stunning interview I encourage you
to check out in total.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at De Packman.
We have a fantastic program planned for you
today.